bonjour je m'appelle marque j'ai 36 ans
bientôt aux 38 g 40 je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai menti et je suis le prochain que
leur apprendre de la flamme
ça fait bientôt dix ans que je suis
pilote de ligne et que je suis
célibataire ça va faire peut-être depuis
mes 10 ans donc depuis toujours et là
commence un peu à faire long pour ça que
je très contente car ces missions faut
que ça s'arrête
j'aime mon métier d'ailleurs je
considère pas mon métier comme un métier
véritablement j'ai pu savoir plus comme
un passe-temps hobby les emmerdes là
quelque chose qu'on fait un peu comme ça
ça je ne vois pas le strasbourg là il
est assez à roissy au la ponctualité
c'est la qualité majeure dont vient de
vivre
bonjour mademoiselle souaqi vilotte
voilà monsieur je veux que les gens se
sentent comme chez eux je les considère
un peu comme des gens de la famille avec
la famille on est aux petits soins
j'adore les amuser les divertir
bienvenue sur ce vol 1 486 en direction
de rio non je plaisante de strasbourg
belle déception pour tous mais c'est
comme ça c'est la vie
un vol c'est long donc je me dis au
temps qui passe ce temps à s'amuser
[Musique]
j'ai toujours jean louis qui a coûté moi
parce que moi les atterrissages et
les décollages ça c'est après je suis
pilote mais j'ai besoin de me connecter
à la nature comme les arbres les
feuilles l'eau les feuilles
j'ai déjà dit parfois j'ai besoin d'être
seul et j'imagine que à côté de moi il
ya la future femme de ma vie
on va partir
moi j'attends d'une femme qu'elle
m'accepte comme je suis après moi je
suis pas obligé de l'accepter comme l
est du fait que faut qu'elle me plaisent
donc si ce qu'elle est ne me plaît pas
alors il faut qu'elle change qui est
laid pour me plaît mais ça c'est normal
c'est la vie chaque personne a les
atouts alors à ce que j'attends de cette
émission passé qu'elle me permettent de
rencontrer la famille et surtout d'être
connu si j'arrive à trouver est la femme
de ma vie et est reconnue alors là c'est
2-2 cerise sur le gâteau un verger pas
prendre deux cerises aux femmes et
fruits le fait de mangue et ce serait
top
vous n'avez pas des mangues on a mangé
beaucoup décoller et j'ai quasiment
jamais atterri je compte sur cette
émission me faire intérêts en beauté
[Musique]